La volta al món a peu, dia 308, són les 7 i 20, m'he llevat més d'hora avui per venir al pont
i aprofitar una mica que, com ahir em van dir que obrien l'oficina a les 8,
doncs jo estic aquí a les 7 i així no he de pagar entrada.
Bueno, fa menys vent que ahir, molt menys vent, per tant estarem millor.
Vaig agafar el mòbil bé. Això és el pont de suspensió de Husseini, que és el poble aquest.
Uau, uau, uau, és molt llarg, eh?
És molt llarg i té molts forats, eh? Compte.
Bueno, vaig a creuar-ho així, va. Vaig a creuar-ho.
Anem a fer-lo sencer, ja que estem aquí.
Avui hi ha menys núvols, per cert.
Es veuen els pics més clarament. Vinga, Vanric, fins que...
Més que res em fa por el mòbil, eh? Uau.
Bueno, es veu sòlid, no tremola massa, eh? Com aquell de...
Com era? Tadjikistan? Sí, Tadjikistan.
Uau, uau, uau, uau, uau, uau.
Jo no sóc tenir por a les altures, eh? Però això impressiona bastant, eh?
Bé, ara estic a la part central. Es mou més per aquí.
Però ara és com que fa menys impressió perquè sota ja no tinc el riu, tinc la sorra.
Que potser em faria més mal i tot, eh? El caure.
El caure aquí.
Creuat, tu, aconseguit. Crec que ha trigat uns 4 o 5 minuts.
I aquí què tenim? Tenim aquesta plataforma que porta allà.
Hi ha una espècie de tirolina. Sí, hi ha una tirolina que tu pots...
Tu pots caure a l'altra banda amb tirolina.
I crec que aquesta espècie de plataforma així artificial,
et porta, si s'haguessis finscaguéss, fins a l'altre pont, el que vam veure ahir, el pont de Passo.
Que ha caigut sa bocatela, eh? Molt bé. Tornem.
Acabat. Ja estava sol, tu.
I tu? Pel que sembla, ja com... Potser t'has de ficar...
Si véns a l'hora oficial, t'has de posar aquest d'això, aquest salvavides.
I allà hi ha com les normes del pont.
Millor. Millor venir ara que no hi ha normes i tal.
Una de les normes diu que no està permès fotografiar a la gent local sense permís.
Em sembla bé, em sembla bé. I jo a vegades sóc culpable d'això.
Encara que, si veieu els meus vídeos, intento, quan faig aquestes vídeos,
de gent sense permís, sempre és d'esquena, no? Normalment, perquè sí, és com el lleig,
encara que fa gràcia, no?, veure la gent que fa i tal. Bueno, fent.
Hi ha bastant de xiringuito aquí muntat. Deu haver-hi bastant turisme en temporada alta,
perquè hi ha un munt de bars, restaurants, tendes de souvenirs...
Bueno, vinga, torno al hostel, agafo la motxilla i comencem a caminar.
¿Cómo se hace lo que hacía una persona tan ligera?
La vida.
Bueno, corté la llave, como me lo dijeron, y la lavas, com me lo dijeron...
¡Y todo!
Yo, ¿cómo se hace lo que hace la persona tan ligera?
A ver, ¿cómo se hace lo que hace la persona tan ligera?
Bueno, igual, ¿cómo se hace lo que hace la persona tan ligera?
¿Cómo se hace lo que hace la persona tan ligera?
¡Aquí!
A aquí!
Bona nit.
Genial, espectacular, la vall de Hunza, que és la de avui, ahir, abans d'ahir, totes aquestes zones, la vall de Hunza, que és el nom del riu aquest, el riu Hunza.
I aquí tenen un idioma que només parlen aquí a tot el món.
Es diu el... és complicat, eh?
Buruix... Buruixisca.
Bé, ho posaré aquí, Buruixisca.
És una llengua que parlen unes 87.000 persones, segons la Wikipedia.
I és una de les llengües del món que està aïllada.
És a dir, no té cap relació, no s'hi sembla, a cap altra llengua del món, no?
Com el basc, també és una llengua aïllada.
Doncs sí, sí, aquesta llengua aquí.
Aquest és el mapa lingüístic que surt a la Wikipedia d'on es parla aquesta llengua.
És aquesta vall i una vall al costat, però que no estan unides.
És a dir, estan separats els parlants d'aquesta llengua.
Això vol dir que probablement en un passat hi havia més parlants i van anar disminuint enfront de l'urdu.
Urdu, urdu, urdu...
Urdu és el que seria el paquistanès.
Què parlen els paquistanesos, paquistanès?
Doncs el paquistanès es diu urdu.
És, atenció, la desena llengua més parlada del món, el loro.
Us presento el llac Atabat.
Un llac molt maco, un entorn molt bonic que, malauradament, ve precedit d'una història molt tràgica.
Això va passar el 2023.
La carretera del Karakorum, us he estat dient que és una de les meravelles del món.
Per què?
Bé, al contrari que el Pamir, que és una zona plana i, bé, més o menys fer una carretera no té tanta complicació,
aquí, com veiem, la carretera segueix un congost format per un riu.
Llavors, clar, les parets són molt verticals i l'erosió és constant i inevitable.
L'home el que pot fer és intentar adaptar-se a aquestes condicions i fer la carretera per un lloc on cregui que no hi haurà tants esprendiments o el que sigui.
Però, cada cop que hi ha pluges fortes,
aquí, les parets són tan verticals i la roca és així, doncs que cada cop hi ha esprendiments i ja es veu, no?
En aquestes esllavissades que hi ha aquí de pedra per tot arreu, per tota la roca.
Doncs, bé, en una d'aquestes, el 2023, així de fa tres anys, va haver-hi un gran esprendiment uns quants quilòmetres més enllà,
aigües avall del riu aquest, i aquest esprendiment va provocar molts morts, molts morts, moltíssims.
Mira, jo, com a enginyer civil, aquesta història que us explicaré i que us estic explicant m'interessa moltíssim,
però, malauradament, no us puc donar les dades molt exactes perquè no hi ha internet.
Ara estic aquí a un cafè que té wifi, però tampoc funciona l'internet del wifi.
Per tant, bueno, us animo a que busqueu la informació més exacta vosaltres mateixos.
Però, bueno, pel que jo sé, aquesta esllavissada, a part d'això, provocar moltes morts, va bloquejar el riu.
I, per tant, el nivell de l'aigua va anar pujant, va anar pujant, fins que va formar aquest llac.
Ara no sembla gran llac, sembla més aviat un riu, no?, un riu ample.
He preguntat aquí al bar aquest i diu que, bueno, això depèn de la temporada, no?
Ara no és temporada de puges o el que sigui, i l'aigua està baixa, però en un moment o altre, doncs, puja.
Després de la formació d'aquest llac, doncs, s'ha creat aquí tota una espècie de complex turístic,
i, bueno, hi ha un munt de restaurants, llocs per a allotjar-te, el que sigui,
i, bueno, quan l'aigua està baixa, doncs hi ha un munt de barques varades i tal, no hi ha molta activitat.
Però sí, i, bueno, ara quan ens apropem més veurem que l'aigua és com molt transparent i tal,
i el que haurem de fer per travessar cap allà és anar per uns túnels, uns túnels.
Són les 12 menys 20, porto aire, eh?
Sí que no vaig a molt bon ritme, però és que, clar, hi ha moltes distraccions.
També us diré que no hi ha gaire pressa.
Al Tajikistà, al Pamir, tenia molta pressa perquè volia creuar el pas de culme abans que comencessin a caure nevades,
a la frontera aquesta abans que la tanquessin, tal.
Ara, més enllà dels 60 dies del visat, puc anar més tranquil i això també està bé, me n'alegro.
No vull anar corrent tota l'estona.
Si he de parar a mirar aquest llac o a prendre'm un cafè i només faig 30 km, doncs tal, el faré.
Encara que avui sí que m'interessava fer els 30 més que em queden, em queden 30, per arribar a comprar des de Tassim.
No sé, ja veu el que faig.
Primer dels túnels que creuaré?
Records del túnel de la mort? Però no, no, no.
Per començar veig que té il·luminació, escassa però il·luminació.
No és gaire llarg, veig el fons.
I bueno, té aquesta espècie de voral que amb ell puc pujar en cas necessari.
També té poc trànsit.
I en general està bastant bé.
Recordeu que, clar, com els cotxes van per l'esquerra, si vull tenir els cotxes de cara jo he d'anar per la dreta.
És bastant intuitiu però és així.
Ostres, tu!
Anava caminant pel túnel aquest, ben il·luminat, tot bé, i ara de cop i volta, fa!
S'apaguen les llums i nit, o sigui, pitch black, completament negre.
Mai havia viscut aquesta sensació, crec.
Mai havia viscut una sensació així.
Foscor al 300%.
No veig absolutament res.
Mai m'havia passat això, eh?
No sé explicar-ho, però...
Bueno, ara ve un cotxe, s'il·lumina una mica, va de res, no passa res, trec el frontal i segueixo caminant.
Túnel superat, en tenim un altre però és més curt.
Mireu, aquí, el llac, molt maco, de color blau, amb tota la seva esplendor.
No posaria la mà al foc perquè, com us dic, no tinc internet, però diria que aquella llavissada que es veu allà al fons és la que ha provocat el llac.
Sí.
T'ho diria. No ho tinc clar, eh?
Doncs no, eh? No és curt.
Ara he mirat el mapa i és llarg.
De fet, el que ha passat eren tres quilòmetres i pico.
I aquest també, tres quilòmetres i pico.
Per cert, posa Pakistan-China Friendship Tunnel número 3.
Per tant, aquest túnel l'han construït els xinesos igual que a Tajikistan, també.
Bé, si aquest túnel tampoc té il·luminació.
Bueno...
No ho sé, si no ésoltat hi ha algun problema de la part de aixina.
No sé si és un problema de l'aixina, però potser sí, però, d'alguna manera, ja és un problema normal.
Així a la zona d'aixina hi ha un mal cas que em fa problemes.
De fet, ara, del PP, l'obligo de dir que, com a mínim, no hi ha mai un problema de la part de aixina.
El més probable, ara, d'aixina, és el mal cas del PP.
Això és evident, el que hem vist, ara ho saps.
Ah, és clar, hi ha un mal cas.
Fins demà!
Home!
Mireu qui m'he trobat, tu!
El que em va convidar el primer dia.
Ja, just now.
Just now, yes.
Did you see the video?
No, I haven't seen yet.
I will see it tonight.
Perfect, perfect.
Bueno, ha passat una cosa molt estranya
que és que amb l'Ikram Hussein
que és l'home aquest que em vaig trobar el primer dia
i que m'he trobat ara
doncs m'ha dit vine, vine
i hem estat aquí, en aquesta taula, en aquest bar
hem fet un te amb ell, els seus amics
i un parell de cosins
hem estat xerrant
i al final he decidit
agafar un hotel per aquí, no anar fins allà dalt
i en algun moment
em succeeixen
potser hauries d'anar cap a l'hotel
agafar-lo, reservar-lo
i després tornes aquí i sopes, perquè jo havia demanat sopar
doncs sí, sí, he anat
he trigat a anar a l'hotel
i tal, 10 minuts
i tornar, i quan he tornat
com veieu
no hi ha ningú, thank you
i el sopar, doncs ara vindrà, suposo
s'han anat
s'han anat, tu
és molt estrany això
bueno, perra
bueno, no sé què és això
m'ho han demanat per mi
l'he preguntat a la IA
ara tinc internet, puc preguntar coses
i diu que es diu diris
és un plat fet amb
això és plat, no?
sembla de plat, no sé què és
i és típic d'aquesta zona, de Junze
anem a provar-ho
molt bo
pica bastant
l'herba, les herbes que porta aquesta
li dona un sabor bastant fresc
però no hi ha cap picat
sembla que faci molt fred, però no fa fred
digue així perquè sí
l'habitació nord de l'altre món
m'ha costat 7 euros
que està força bé
i la dutxa, fins demà al matí res
ahir, igual
crec que
i fa dos dies també
tots els dies que he estat al Pakistan
la dutxa sempre m'han dit, pel matí
perquè tot el dia necessita 6 o 7 hores
per calentar el dipòsit d'aigua
que fa que surti l'aigua
i no el tenen preparat
si no saben que vindrà un turista
llavors això, sí, sí, sí
t'has d'esperar tota la nit
que calenti tan poc a poc
tan poc a poc el dipòsit
i després et dutxes
bueno, tot és igual
avui m'he gastat només 11 euros i mig
al sopar, quan anava a pagar
m'han dit que l'icra
icram, icram oceín
l'home aquest m'havia convidat
així que, si estàs veient això
moltíssimes gràcies, està molt bo
i què més
i després avui
refrescos, cap, un suc
i un piquet
per ahir, o tres
dos, dos tests
dos tests, he parlat amb
avui posa-li
tres persones
quatre, quatre, quatre persones
ha sigut un dia genial
un dia, bueno ja us ho he dit abans, hi ha hagut de tot
de tot, m'ho he passat molt bé
de quilòmetres 37
avui ja una cosa més decent
avui molt bé, i això que
tampoc he sortit a les 8, saps?
podria sortir abans, no, molt bé, molt bé
ostres tu, m'està encantant aquests dies de Pakistan, m'ho estic passant molt bé
els passatges són increïbles
i ara parlant
amb el cosí de
de l'home aquest
com ell treballa aquí
el tema del turisme, m'ha recomanat
alguns trekkings
n'hi ha un que ja no és temporada
i que s'ha de pagar un guia obligatori, aquest no el anirem
era un llac a 5.000 metres
tenia bona pinta però no aniré
i m'ha recomanat un altre que és
el camp base d'una muntanya que hi ha aquí
que comença per R, que no recordo el nom
i aquest crec que sí que el faré
sí, serà
dos dies però, bueno, encara no
serà d'aquí uns quants dies
demà visitaré Hunza
i potser camino una mica
no ho tinc clar perquè Hunza i tota aquesta
zona hi ha bastanta cosa a veure
per tant
el que calgui, si cal
estar tot el dia perquè és molt xulo
doncs hi estaré
i després he d'anar fins al
principi del trekk i després fer el trekk del camp base aquest
bueno
què més?
tema de les samarretes
tenim el proveïdor que és un
bé, és molt professional el proveïdor que tenim
i s'equivoquen les comandes
les envia molt tard
per exemple em comenta el Daniel que
li hem fet una comanda doncs a tres samarretes
de dona i les porta d'home
saps? coses així
llavors estem pensant
en canviar el proveïdor però bueno
mentre no canviem doncs les samarretes doncs
potser que
arribin i estan arribant doncs
més tard del que toca
també potser com hi ha bon ritme
i hi ha bona venda
potser el que fem és agafar estoc
però bueno tot això s'ha de parlar, també estem parlant
d'afegir nous productes
ja de cara a l'hivern, potser una jaqueta tal
ara bueno s'ha de veure perquè
com em vindran a visitar
jo us vaig dir quan acabi Pakistan
doncs em portaran coses
i bueno ja us ho ensenyaré si tal
res més tu
bona nit
Fins demà